hello and welcome in this video i
explain to you what an analysis of
variance a so-called anova is and how
you can calculate it there are different
types of analyses of variance this video
is about the one-way or single factor
analysis of variance without measurement
repetitions and that's where we start
the first question is why do you need an
analysis of variance at all what does an
analysis of variance do
an analysis of variance checks whether
there are statistically significant
differences between more than two groups
therefore the analysis of variance is
the extension of the t-test for
independent samples to more than two
groups when calculating an independent
t-test we looked at whether there is a
difference or more precisely a
difference in means between two
independent groups for example if there
is a difference in the salary of men and
women in this case we have two groups
the man's group and the women's group if
we want to compare more than two
independent groups we use the analysis
of variance in case of the t-test we
used an independent t-test if the two
groups or samples were independent this
is the case if one person in the first
group has nothing to do with a person
from the second group exactly the same
now applies to the analysis of variance
without repeated measures except that
here we have at least three independent
samples
if we have more than two dependent
samples we would use an analysis of
variance with repeated measures now
let's look at an example
let's say that as the founder of datatab
i might be interested in whether there
are differences in the age between
people who use data tab spss or r in
order to do this i take a sample of
people who use statistical software and
ask them which statistical software they
use and how old they are i've only
compared three groups in this example of
course there could also be more groups
in order to analyze this example i would
now use an anova so the next question is
what is the research question i can
answer with using an anova
the research question is is there a
difference in a population between the
different groups of the independent
variable
in relation to the dependent variable
the independent variable is the variable
with the different categories in our
example it is the statistics software
used here we have the three groups
datadeb spss and r the dependent
variable in our example is the age of
the software users we would like to know
whether the groups of the independent
variables have an influence on the
dependent variable of course the
analysis of variance does not give us
any information about the direction of
the causal relationship but why is our
research question about the population
don't we just have a sample
actually we want to make a statement
about the population unfortunately in
most cases it is not possible to survey
the whole population and we can only
draw a sample the aim is to make a
statement about the population based on
our sample with the help of the analysis
of variants for our example the question
would be is there a difference between
the users of different statistical
software solutions in terms of age
but what about the hypotheses
in the case of the analysis of variance
the null hypothesis is that there are no
differences between the means of the
individual groups we have our individual
groups of which we can calculate the
mean in each case and our null
hypothesis is that there is no
difference in the mean in a population
the alternative hypothesis h1 is that
there is a difference between at least
two group means
therefore our null hypothesis assumes
that there is no difference and the
alternative hypothesis says that there
is a difference all well and good now we
know what the null hypothesis is but
what does this mean graphically how can
one picture that vividly
let's say we want to test whether there
is a difference in salary between the
three groups group 1 group 2 and group
3. the salary has some dispersion some
people earn 400 euros a month some 2 600
and others 6 000 euros a month thus both
in the population and in our sample the
salary is broadly distributed now the
question is where does this variation
come from and can we explain some of the
variation by these three groups so how
much of the variation in salary can we
explain by dividing the people into
these three groups in the extreme case
the result could be that the salary in
group 1 has this distribution
in group 2 that distribution and in
group 3 the distribution would look like
this
in this case the division into groups
could explain a lot of variance in a
variable salary the result would be
different in this case
here however we could explain almost no
variance by forming the three groups
within the groups the variance is almost
the same as in the whole sample
therefore it does not matter whether we
form the groups or not the three groups
have nearly no influence on the salary
if we now look at the variance within
the groups we can see that in this case
we have very small variances within the
groups so within this group we have a
very small variance within that group we
have a small variance and also in the
last group on the other hand the
variance between the groups is very
large because the mean values of the
individual groups are very far apart
in the other case we have a very large
variance within the groups however the
variance between the groups is very
small because the mean values of the
groups are very close together how can
we calculate an anova there are two
possibilities for the calculation either
you use a statistic software like
datatab or you calculate the analysis of
variance by hand
admittedly no one will calculate the
analysis of variance by hand
but the knowledge is very helpful to
understand more precisely how an
analysis of variance works in this video
i show you how you can easily calculate
an analysis of variance online with data
tab to calculate an analysis of variance
with data tab just visit
datadeb.net you can find the link in the
video description below
then you copy your own data into this
table
and click on this tab
under this tab you will find a variety
of hypotheses tests
here below you can see the variables you
copied into the table
depending on which variables you select
data tab will calculate the appropriate
hypothesis test
if you click on a matrix variable and a
nominal variable with at least three
characteristics
datadab calculates an analysis of
variance here you can read the p-value
if you don't know exactly how to
interpret the p-value just get the
summary inverts above
furthermore you can check the
assumptions of the analysis of variance
here
thanks for watching and i hope you
enjoyed the video
you